I've been thinking for a while about
whether to do this story that I'm going
to do right now and I've been thinking
about it generally for a couple of
months and more intensely for the last
ten days or so and the reason I've been
has it's and I'll just be totally
upfront with you is that I know it's
going to have a negative impact on my
show because of a specific segment of
the audience let me set it up for you
about ten days ago Tim Poole who's an
independent journalist he says he
center-left he knows I see him as really
an antagonize er of the left primarily
we disagree about this it's no big deal
people disagree about things and that's
totally fine and he tweeted about ten
days ago
quote my lefty friends message me every
so often that they are scared of
speaking out against the far-left
because they will get attacked because
they won't push back on the far-left
Dems don't see opposition and embrace
woek Twitter this will lead to Trump's
2020 landslide and my reaction was this
is Tim agitating again and I wrote back
on Twitter quote I'd be genuinely
curious who those lefty friends are I've
never met anyone in lefty independent
media who's afraid of just saying what
they believe period I would love to
interview someone prominent who can talk
about these fears that they have and
then a few hours went by and I had to be
honest with myself it's not a fear of
the far-left
that I have but I am one of those people
Tim talked about who is scared about
dealing with certain issues in the way I
want to deal with them not because they
go against the quote far-left or because
I'm afraid of calling out what I see is
the far left I think that's the wrong
terminology terminology but I've been
pushed away from talking about certain
topics at least in a certain way because
I realized there's no upside my core
audience will agree bright wingers will
disagree as they often do but there is
this sliver of the left that will be so
furious with me that they will wreak
havoc over our entire online presence
YouTube's emailing tweeting all of this
stuff for two weeks if I say certain
things and there's really very
upside to doing that so I want to before
I even go any further let me be like
insanely clip crystal-clear here to
avoid any misunderstandings I'm not
having a right wing awakening okay this
is not me changing the show to be
critical of small slices of the left and
focus on the more than they actually
deserve to be focused on this is not me
saying I've changed my mind on any
political issue this is me just
admitting that I've been sort of pushed
away from dealing with certain stories
as frequently as I might otherwise deal
with them because when I tell the truth
as I see it about these stories there is
a slice of the left that goes so bonkers
that it is simply not worth it
so let's talk about some specifics I'm
gonna give you examples of what I mean
and I know that I am causing hell to
rain down upon me as a result of doing
this but I'm just going to tell it the
way I see it just the other day I got a
call from someone who told me hey David
people of color can't be racist and
white people can't be the victims of
racism and I just said it the way I saw
it the way I see it my position is super
clear in the United States most
frequently people of color are the
victims of racism and not the racists
and white people frequently are the
perpetrators and not the victims of
racism but white people can be victims
of racism people of color can be racist
and we need to distinguish between
racism and depression on the basis of
race I haven't said a word about it
since I covered it two weeks ago because
a small part of the left went absolutely
unhinged made the day-to-day of my
online experience insufferable which I
know is their goal now I'm a big boy I
can take it I'm okay but it pushes me
away from continuing to hit the wasps
nest with a stick every single day when
I talk about Tulsi Gabbard there is no
other 2020 candidate that I can talk
about casually as I sometimes have about
Tulsi Gabbard that will trigger the
level of hatred and violence --is as
when I mentioned Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi is
a presidential candidate polling about
1% when I talk about other candidates
who poll 1% Amy Klobuchar Bill DeBlasio
whoever the reactions are to the content
of what I say and if I talk about Tulsi
Gabbard the Tulsi sycophants
lose their minds they smear me they
slander me the way they did to the Young
Turks ana kasparian when she did a
segment about Tulsi so do I not talk
about Tulsi now I talk about her but I
avoid getting too involved
she's polling 1% she's gonna go away
soon why talk that much about Tulsi when
the followers are truly toxic and there
is very little upside let's talk about
the squad those four ethnic minority
Congress women I basically don't talk
about them because I can't do any
serious critique without being called a
racist without being told that I am a
centrist Democratic establishment chill
now you'll notice if you watch the show
the last ten days I have been covering
this absolutely horrible xenophobic
racist treatment of the squad by Donald
Trump recently but that's safe right if
I try to issue any kind of critique of
the squad whatsoever for example I have
questions about their strategy while
very inspired and principled will the
strategy and tactics of the squad
achieve legislative goals because I view
them as lacking the political savvy to
understand how coalition work coalitions
work to understand how politics achieves
things in the United States and if I
have that conversation and I tried
before
David you racist David you centrist
Nancy Pelosi Phil my politics are to the
left of Hillary my politics are to the
left of Biden my politics are to the
left of Pelosi but I am very skittish
about doing any kind of critique of the
squad because there's a sliver of the
left that will punish me every time and
I wonder is it even really worth it I
have other things to talk about
yesterday on the bonus show we talked
about another issue which I know is like
a tinderbox issues of gender and
parenting around gender and trans issues
there is no stronger supporter of trans
rights than me use any bathroom you want
I don't care it should be illegal to
fire someone because of their gender
identity because of a change to their
gender identity because of their status
as a trans individual we should use the
gender pronouns for people that they
want us to use when we address them or
refer to
I'm all for it but I worry about pushing
gender neutrality on kids to a degree
that doesn't make sense empirically the
truth is and I said this yesterday on
the bonus show I know I'm opening up
Pandora's box
the truth is statistically very few kids
experience gender related issues in the
sense of being born with male genitalia
and feeling as though they're female or
vice versa or being non-binary etc and
I've seen no evidence that pushing
gender neutrality to the degree of don't
refer to my baby as he or she total
neutrality with toys and clothes
shielding the children themselves from
their gender I think that there's a good
chance this does more damage than good
and the truth is kids live in the world
they live in society they will see
representations of boys and girls in
media if they have a question about
their gender identity they're going to
know it even if we treat them as boys or
girls as they grow up I will be called
transphobic for this statement and it's
why I stay away from the topic
altogether I dealt with it on the bonus
show yesterday some people emailed me
and said David you really should just
say what you think on your your regular
public broadcast show another issue
Israel and Palestine I believe that I am
in agreement with the bulk of leftists
on 95% of the israeli-palestinian
conflict
I am completely against the
administration of Benjamin Netanyahu
because I'm on the left and he's on the
right I'm against the legal settlements
in the Palestinian territories I believe
they must stop immediately I want to
find the most direct path possible to
ending the Gaza blockade I want to
return sovereignty over the Palestinian
territories including East Jerusalem in
a solution that I want to advance as
quickly as possible but I don't believe
Israel is uniquely bad as an actor I
don't believe IDF soldiers have any
unique bloodlust relative to the
militaries and armies of other countries
I believe that if the goal were simply
let's kill as many Palestinian civilians
as possible the death toll would be
untold orders of magnitude higher and I
do believe that there is way more veiled
anti-semitism within the anti Israeli
movement than men
on the left like to admit but we
basically agree on policy and this is
another topic I tend to shy away from
given the option of talking about that
or something else I tend to shy away
because laying out what I just laid out
is a huge risk for me because of that
slice of the left Venezuela as many of
you know I'm against American regime
change in Venezuela I'm against American
involvement in Venezuela I know being
from Argentina the history of disastrous
American involvement in Latin America
but I also think the Shabbos and Maduro
regimes have been disastrous for
Venezuela and its people and merely
saying that causes a slice of the left
to say that even if I say I'm against
regime change merely by criticizing
Maduro I am legitimizing regime change
by the United States and fomenting or
enabling the America American
involvement in Venezuela I can't win so
I shy away from it if the right
obviously disagrees with me on all of
these issues so who cares right but if
I'm totally honest with myself and with
you I do shy away from certain topics
because of what I know will be a toxic
reaction from a slice of the left I will
lose financial support because of this
story I mean that this is the saddest
thing guaranteed doing this story that
right now these 1012 minutes we're gonna
spend talking about this I will lose
financial support even though I've
clarified that nothing has changed I
hold all of the exact positions as I
always have but merely spelling this out
will lead some people to cancel their
memberships will lead some people to
cancel their patreon pledges but I've
decided to tell you that this is going
on that this self-censorship is going on
I've repeated many times when YouTube
videos get D monetized I could say let
me pick stories that will remain
monetized I've never done that and
fortunately we've been growing our
indirect financial support where it
hasn't become a financial choice that I
have to make I do the stories I think
are important with regard to
monetization but the truth is that the
blowback that there's been from a sliver
of the left totally toxic blowback on
some stories
pushed me away from talking about
certain issues as much and it's not a
good thing and electorally it's a
concern as well because as I've talked
about much of what Donald Trump does is
designed to divide the left and we need
to resist that because we need to keep
our eyes on the ball and there's so many
other reasons why that's important a
similar analysis applies here as well we
really just need to be talking about
what's important to discuss and the fact
that I admit I have self-censored around
some issues because of these blowback
totally toxic reaction concerns that I
have it's not good in any way shape or
form now it is possible and this is
where you know I just have to understand
that this is the dynamic the reactions
the taking over of all of our social
media platforms and the email writing
campaigns and the tweets and everything
to some degree it probably is designed
to get me to stay away from the topics
and I I mean I feel terrible that in a
sense it has worked
but I'm laying it out for you and I'm
being completely transparent with you
about the reality that this is something
that has been going on I want to hear
from you what's your reaction what do
you think I will absolutely tell you
what happens in the next week is the
result of me coming clean about this I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman follow me there
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show i look forward to hearing from you